de retour pour une troisième année au
hellfest on vient vous embêter on vient
d'ailleurs tout le monde voilà on vient
faire des bisous aux copains on va faire
des vidéos copains écouter de la bonne
musique on évoque plein plein de trucs
et on est très content de pouvoir faire
ça avec vous voit la troisième fois au
hellfest pour ma part un oui est
chouette quatrième pour moi ces rôles
bien rigoler peut-être pas grandi depuis
non toujours pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non bon eh ouais pas mal comment on peut
lire des ebooks des carottes courgettes
carottes à lui la fin comment nos villes
mais angoula gros burger leur ont rien à
voir
la bouffe du vite c'est pas ces
festivals non ils allaient voir
clairement où j'allais voir les intérêts
de quinoa mais laurent quartier salades
tartes la gagne un lot de semences est
bien mais séparés festival boulgour s'y
fait pas de quel poste
on a quoi tartare de boeuf c'est bien ce
qui importe c'est bien mais c'est pas
trés le feu qui est financier petits
cakes aux citrons part peut être
amboise c'est bien mais c'est pas très
sympa très le fait d'avoir gagné un gros
burger
moi ce que je te conseille c'est de
manger elle si une grosse carotte
moi je compte propre à 40 voix là c'est
très bizarre on va le faire
[Musique]
c'est quoi la chanson s'est longtemps
parcouru son corps est plus sympa sans
visage hâlé des vrais bonhomme tient à
ce qui est quand même incroyable c'est
le nombre de personnes obèses toi tout
pendant six mois je me préparais à
aschbach de ce qui est quand même ouf
c'est le nombre de personnes qui
utilisent toute la journée
mais qu'est ce que tu es grand qu'est ce
que t'es grenat répète ça n'arrête pas
c'est bien d'arriver à 5 minutes de
toute personne qui pense que l'on sera
50 60
une fois les objectifs rien qu'à ses
objectifs il est là le cléo mais toi
notre niveau s'il te plaît mario est un
bébé je le savais les gâteaux tombe bien
ouais ça vas y toi
j'adore c'est quoi la mâchoire qui
expliquent le déguisement
mais vous faites les daltons nous est
promis telegraph c'est qu'il plus malins
minus et cortex et geniki bank nab hier
sur le monde qui comptent toujours le
grand dadais j'en ai marre tout seul
elle casse les couilles je crois
d'ailleurs broulis bonjour de santé du
moment il aux mamans promis je fais pas
de bêtises
[Musique]
être tué mais mano à mano avec j'ai vu
le concert des super et j'ai adoré
on attend à manoir 24 ont cette fois le
roc pour moi y'a d'oublier la moto
rennes didier quillot
moi j'assume la sas à son bord de la
save
on attaque
c'est du ruisseau
ce qui ne tue pas nous rend plus forts
reprendre mears
je m'en suis vachement fort dans la vie
de toutes façons assez rock'n'roll puis
la lenny kravitz
moi j'adore le rock l'année dernière on
s'est fait insulter mon ses blagues je
te rappelle ce n'est pas toi les décors
[Applaudissements]
à
et nous une blague on va se faire
insulter selimi kravitz ou encore les
annonces américaines moman qui me désole
le bouton privé non mais c'est pas une
intox a dit persuadé que l'ol fasse avec
un coup c'est mugello j'ai le vertige
elle en est l'auteur pourquoi tu te
tiens aux poteaux comme ça là parce que
j'ai le vertige
artix b
[Musique]
du coup c'est monsieur greu effet de
nombreuses questions on a gagné
[Musique]
aurélie est à manger là à ce propos le
tapioca d'eni frac et dans t'aurais pu
faire gaffe à tes dans l excuse moi là
qu'est ce tu fais sans relief 3d vision
bailly brandt
il passe
sa mission faire découvrir les bijoux
animé le stand aller voir les gens leur
donner des prises
venu vous dise moi je suis bouddhiste
kadhafi dit salut toi tu ne comprends
pas nous ce truc là take n'y a pas
beaucoup ce superflic par ici c'est le
super flic baby feet high havana paul
ayah bnp naipaul on écoute de la très
bonne écoute de la fiole rendez-vous de
plein de groupes
bref on découvre plein pour des coupes
d'un groupe on découvre que le groupe
on n'est que dans les deux volets de
voix là et merci aux organes nous avons
accrédité vieille piste allait la voir
on vous a vu aussi une très ancienne
dans son équipe
on va pas se mentir on n'a plus notre
troisième fête ensemble mon petit boulot
ouais voilà ces chèques c'est
intelligent on est pas mal et c'est
waouh c'est la première d'un conseil le
cornac et c'est plutôt sympa on était
pas mal
il y avait une espèce de fontaine avec
ou sans piscine
il y avait une piscine donc là c'est pas
mal mais n'a pas regardé couteau avec
pour tout le club les pieds elle fait
school élevé scouts plein de concerts
cool
ouais grave par contre j'ai pas en clair
envers convient de se taper se relayer
leurs là c'était super mois et par
enfant qui parle aux gens que je
commence en loge briques par contre j'ai
pas trop compris on en vendait quoi
entre autres entre autres entre y pas de
mal entre autres il y avait dit hier
c'est de cette merde
c'était vous manque la merde non pas
dire ça je suis bien à marseille 1 comme
un gros passé non mais c'est vrai qu'à
25 ans c'est peut-être bien quoi
répondre
mais aujourd'hui c'était un petit peu
dur d'y croire en fait voilà on n'y
croyait pas trop si on n'était pas trop
dedans on a bu des coups
vachement cool merci de l'équipe du
hellfest fidèles
merci roger la super bien merci aux ars
et les abonnés soyez cool envoyer des
like de l'amour en commencèrent on veut
de l'amour voilà vous à moi pour vous m
non je vais mieux je vous scène bisous
bisous revoit sa came 1.3 sa caméra
tâches auprès de me dire et j'ai chopé
le menu ce but sur la balance achète toi
tu n'essaies croisés tu laisses a croisé
hors scène en fait j'ai pas dans les
studios first d'ajeddou barrières d'un
manoir est va devoir c'était bien les
bornes à génial génial a su quel était
le problème avec le choc et c'est donc
elle cause de toi qui sont partis mais
c'est sache ce qu'il vit à toronto parce
qu'on est vrai qu'ils ont peu joué parce
qu'ils ont la grosse tête
pour moi c'est comme la vallée du
denacre le problème c'est que n'y avait
pas assez de lapin pour faire les slips
crois qu'on a tous les milk et mickey
oui axl rose car axel et a chanté on va
les rabibocher et je te donne croyais
pas ce que nous en fait on est des gens
très intelligents mais devant le
hellfest à clisson et on dort à nantes
ça n'a aucun sens